not everybody in this conference should
be making videos on the internet they're
not good at it and that's okay you can
practice and get better but maybe it's
just not for you and that's okay I think
the biggest problem today is that most
people feel to be good at social media
you have to be on camera and that is
crazy you have a business when you have
a business you do not have to be on
camera it's a good thing to be on camera
if you like it or you're good at it you
should be on camera but if you are not
good at it and you do not like it and
you genuinely understand yourself I know
no matter how much I practice singing I
will only be so good I will be better in
a year if I practice singing every day
then I would sing tonight but I'll still
be at a very low level I can never be
Beyonce